[Music]
Beauty style a sense of the exquisite
this scene is designed to awaken a
longing for luxury we've come to
nymphenburg palace in Munich workers
here are setting the table a process
that will take three hours it's all for
the purpose of producing photos for a
new coffee table book on fine dining we
provided the porcelain and how much is
it worth 150 thousand euros on dose
Thomas heads the nymphenburg porcelain
manufactory it produces directly at the
palace using centuries-old techniques
the porcelain is not pressed but shaped
by hand on a potter's wheel every plate
that leaves the manufactory goes through
this process
this is the bean rotating it this way
gives the plate a certain stability so
we can shape it more thinly without it
cracking a single dinner plate from the
cumberlands series costs over 4,000
euros sheikhs from the arab world with a
passion for dining in the style of 18th
century European Royals are among the
company's customers the flowers are
painted by hand a process that takes
three weeks per plate
but it's not just the dinner service the
silverware the table linen and the
glasses are all equally exquisite the
photos are designed to show just how
fine fine dining can be publisher
Marcela pre or call they commissioned
the book winces when we see this as art
or perhaps that's a bit of an
exaggeration but it's certainly very
advanced in terms of taste and style so
in that sense it perhaps really is an
expression of our society that we're
capturing on camera here did facade and
its advertising for the partner firms of
course the partner firms are those who
have provided the table where the silver
and the glasses the bosses pose for the
camera and take the opportunity to
promote their products you doing there
something we can reveal that we have a
glass series that will come out with
potion go in September yon krona is in
charge of the project as a florist he
likes to put together unusual displays
preferably using seasonal flowers
[Music]
it's a toy now we have tulips then
peonies then fragrant roses then you get
the amazing dahlias and in the fall it's
back to amaryllis no one here feels it's
over the top to put this much effort
into setting a table mad at both of
these my message is all about the art of
fine dining that's an asset that we
don't want to lose and we exert
ourselves to ensure that this knowledge
is passed on the art of fine dining is
an asset that creates business for these
tableware manufacturers they're all keen
to attract new customers but no one will
get to dine at this table as soon as the
photos have been taken the whole thing
will be cleared again
[Music]
you